what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so as I was going through and I was
doing all the prep work for our run on
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers one
of the things that I ended up realizing
is that we had not really done the
Ultimate Universe side of things in a
lot of ways and the reason for that is
this the Ultimate Universe was
interesting to me but whatever was I
just kind of went through and read like
the collapse of the multiverse and
Marvel Comics I only stayed in the main
Marvel Universe side and never went to
the ultimate universe side but the cool
thing about the ultimate universe is
that while it did originally form in
2000 while it was Marvel's way to
basically say what if superheroes
existed in the real world and what would
that world look like in truth the death
of spider-man Peter Parker and the
ultimate spider-man comics basically
offered Marvel a chance to kind of
rework everything I mean in truth it's
actually as close to a reboot as we've
ever gotten from Marvel Comics things
kind of continued on but you could
literally just read like the death of
spider-man and the events that you know
tie into it and whatever you need to
read in order to understand it and then
just go directly into the Ultimate
Universe after that it's really a fresh
jumping-off point because things happen
we're like Captain America and the
Ultimate Universe
quits because he believes that if he had
trained Peter Parker he wouldn't have
died and then we get things like this
which is the origin story of Thor now
and the Ultimate Universe the origin
story of Thor it kind of exists but is
interspersed throughout the Ultimates
comics of course The Ultimates being the
ultimate Universal vengers and so it's
just kind of interspersed you know
throughout that line of stories what
this does is it actually consolidates it
all and it takes a lot of the continuity
errors that existed with regards to
ultimate Thor's origin as it existed in
the ultimate and it condenses it down
and it makes it easier to digest and it
makes it pretty straightforward and so
one thing we need to keep in mind is
that this is not like Thor from the main
Marvel Universe he'll find his return to
godhood
but even then his adventures won't be as
grandiose and as huge in spectacle as
the main Marvel Universe
the thing about ultimate universe is
that it's largely confined to earth and
so because of this the way that Odin's
son is depicted here is actually pretty
cool now what we do here is we initially
pick up really with the European Super
Soldier program now remember in the
Ultimate Universe one of the biggest
differences is that Captain America
Steve Rogers was not the first test
subject for the Super Soldier Serum the
first successful test subject was Nick
Fury and so with Nick Fury proving to be
the successful test subject this serum
was then administered
to Captain America's Steve Rogers the
result is that he became the same kind
of Captain America that were the most
familiar with from the main Marvel
Universe and in the same origin story
playing out the same way dr. Abraham
Erskine the guy who had basically given
Captain America the serum had ended up
dying and so because of this what it did
is it basically led to this you know
quote-unquote Super Soldier Serum race
so to speak in this sense you had all
these major powers across the world
Russia Germany all of them basically
making this mad dash to have their own
Super Soldier program but with Thor we
don't really know much about him all we
know is that he's just here one day now
for whatever reason the European
government had basically looked at him
as the best suitable candidate for their
own super soldier program but the
difference here is he's not being given
a serum he's basically being given a
belt a harness and some means to control
the weather and so on and so forth so
it's actually kind of cool the way this
plays out now of course the indication
here in terms of why he was such a great
specimen is because he's just built
really well I mean look at the guy guys
got muscles on top of muscles it's
absolutely insane not only that though
the biggest issue the European
governments coming across is that he's
literally just scribbling all these
different things that are in some
ancient language that nobody really
seems to be able to understand save for
a guy named Donald Blake now this is
kind of interesting and it actually gets
a little bit hairy when you start
getting into the Donald Blake character
originally in Marvel Comics back when
Thor first popped up Donald Blake and
Thor were two sides of the same coin the
idea was that when Thor resided in
Asgard he was arrogant he was full of
hubris Odin wanted to teach him a lesson
in humility and so he cast him to earth
and basically stripped his knowledge of
the fact that he was Thor and placed him
in the body of a guy named Donald Blake
who was basically a doctor the idea was
that treating the sick treating the
enfermo so couldn't take care of
themselves would teach Thor humility and
when the time came where he had the
option to lift his hammer this humility
would either prove itself to make him
worthy or he would not prove itself and
he would just simply stay unworthy the
result was that he picked it up
realizing that he was Thor and so what
ended up happening is Marvel went
forward with this kind of Superman Clark
Kent alter-ego situation in the sense
that when Odin son was being a superhero
he was Thor when he was being a regular
person he was Donald Blake now because
of the fact that alter egos basically
began to become a thing of the past and
the
since that unless you were spider-man
Batman or Superman you really didn't
have a reason for an alter ego
eventually the Donald Blake persona
began to just weed out and the result
was that most every single story that we
ever saw almost never featured Donald
Blake instead it only ever featured Thor
now of course what this also does is
this leads directly into the
introduction of a character named Balder
now Balder is really interesting when it
comes to Marvel comics and the reason
for this is because again Keamy teens
can find a marvel as opposed to the real
world Norse mythology the death of
Balder is supposed to signify the coming
of Ragnarok which is to say the
destruction of Asgard now the biggest
reason why this is an issue is because
as far as I am aware Balder did not die
before the events of the original
Ragnarok and the main Marvel stories
which is to say thor ragnarok that
actual story itself instead it was
actually Odin who died he died at the
hands of Surtur the idea is that this is
the reason why if you go back and you
read the last days of Loki and Loki
agent of passcard we end up finding out
but the cycle of Ragnarok can actually
never be stopped that it always goes on
forever and ever and ever Thor's tried
to stop it an infinite number of times
before
and he's always failed every single time
within the ultimate universe Balder his
death does signify the coming of
Ragnarok again very realistic very much
playing into the concept of how it's
supposed to be and so in this instance
Balder is the biological son of Odin and
Frigg aware as Thor is the biological
son of Odin and Gaia and then of course
Loki is the biological son of a frost
giant as' and Odin himself so really
baller is the only true son of Odin but
again these characters basically make up
the warriors 3 of course Loki Thor and
Balder and that's really about it now
this is not significant it's not hugely
important it's just a sign to show us
that these guys really hang out these
guys basically chill and have fun and
like battle is how it is they celebrate
their moments and so on and so forth
it's also the idea that Odin is having a
hammer commissioned for Thor basically
this hammer that will imbue part of
Odin's power now the other half of this
is that Odin is vastly different in the
ultimate universe versus the main Marvel
counterpart again we'll talk more about
that as we progress through the story
but transitioning back to 1939 with the
Germans what we end up having is
basically Baron Helmut Zemo and Baron
Zemo and the idea here is that we
essentially have them grabbing the noise
the nornes depending on what line of
publications were talking about change
in different ways in the ultimate
universe the norms are a means by which
people can basically access the
Asgardian realms that's really what it
is you don't need the Bifrost you can
just use the nornes and then walk into
any one of these wells in the main
Marvel Comics the nornes are actually
these super powerful artifacts kind of
like the Asgardian version of the
Infinity stones to a degree they don't
really let you warp reality per se but
they do give you the power of godhood
that's how it is that that Thor became
rune King Thor after absorbing these
norms and then just becoming like this
crazy demigod being it's really kind of
weird you only see him for a short
amount of times in the confines of that
story but here in this one basically
it's the idea that there are twenty-four
Norn stones twenty-one of which can be
arranged in any particular order by
threes and then you can access the
different realms based on how you
restructure them the last three will
actually be a major talking point for
the end of this video but because of the
fact that the Germans are basically
trying to find ways to access this s
Guardian weaponry so on and so forth for
the purpose of winning World War two
what is up happening is they actually
access the realm of the frost giants
which is really kind of cool here
because when they do this basically
begins the process of initiating
Ragnarok what we end up doing is we
actually switch over to you know again
the point that was ages ago
with the discussion between Odin and and
and Thor and this is where I said we
would talk about the power of Odin
within the realm of the Ultimate
Universe because of the fact of the
alternate universe is designed to be
more grounded Odin as he exists here is
not godly which is to say he's not this
near omnipotent almost indestructible
being like he is in the main Marvel
Universe instead he's really more of
just a guy who ties Asgard to the
existing plane which is to say he is as
guard and Asgard is hip like Odin really
goes to Thor and somebody just says if I
am destroyed Asgard will be destroyed as
well I am the life force by which Asgard
floats I am the source of its energy and
it's the source of my energy the two go
hand-in-hand the other half of this is
that when it comes to the hammer of Thor
he's basically he's really Odin just
kind of doing his own power into the
hammer per se and then that's how it is
that he determines who can wield it and
who can't now this is actually a much
better explanation than we got when it
came to the main Marvel Universe and the
main Marvel Universe originally it was
just odd and crafted the hammer of Thor
and like he put a spell on it only those
where they could lift it we didn't
really know why it was so powerful
except for the fact that it had
something to do with magic it wasn't
until the last year or so that Marvel
came along and said well actually inside
of this hammer is the sentience norm
capable of wiping out half the universe
or something that crazy so he's
channeling this is the same level of
energy which is why the hammer is so
capable and that's really about it
there's really no explanation there it's
just kind of how the way it works and so
again this provides a far more tangible
explanation because within the hammer is
part of Odin's essence and so you could
almost imagine that the essence inside
of the hammer can think for itself and
so somebody who walks up and tries to
pick up the hammer the essence of Odin
says actually you're not worthy so I'm
not gonna let you lift me and it's a far
more simple and a far easier to
understand explanation in terms of how
it works now of course the other half of
this is in the modern day when we deal
with the Donald Blake persona we deal
with this Thor character and the idea
that the European governments trying to
figure out what's going on the biggest
struggle of the European government has
is yes they live in a world where there
are beings who can fly around yes they
live in a world where there are beings
who have all manner of powers and a guy
who can crawl on walls yes these
characters are very capable but going to
the European government and saying hey
we have this guy who can turn into like
a giant mean version of himself that's
gray is far easier to explain as opposed
to we have this guy who claims that he's
like the Thor from Norse mythology and
like we believe it like at that point it
just sounds bonkers and I know it's kind
of weird it seems weird to say that but
again that's the basis of the ultimate
universe is that it's really a measure
of what you can see as opposed to what
you can't see but what we end up doing
is we basically pick up with the fall of
the frost giants now remember in the
ultimate universe when it came to the
frost giants being defeated it was
basically this idea that Odin procreated
with a frost giant giant as a female
frost giant for the purpose of seeding
and air and then essentially saying this
air will basically be the truce by which
we function I will take this air as my
own he will be a continuation of your
legacy should something ever happen to
you but until then you stay away I stay
away everybody's fun the issue with this
is that it led ultimately to this truce
that nobody is really happy with and so
because of that look you literally goes
to see his mom and says I know you're
angry I know you hate living here I know
you don't like it here but you are my
mother I have more
you than I do to Odin tell me what you
want and I will give it to you and she
basically says get me the noise and so
this directly leads into the idea that
it's effectively Loki again continuing
the cycle of Ragnarok now of course what
it also comes to Asgard at least access
to Asgard it's not done by traditional
means which is to say there isn't really
a Bifrost per se really it's just like
Heimdall guarding the entryway to to
Asgard which is to say anybody who's
able to travel to a location rearrange
these nornes and then in turn access
Asgard Heimdall will stop them if
they're not supposed to be there now
remember Heimdall is one of these
characters where he's one of the most
powerful as Guardians he's not the most
powerful because of this the evolution
of his character and the strength that
he's capable of has been contextual over
the years in this scenario he's taken
out by an arrow to the eye but it
actually turned out to be interesting
and the reason why is because this is
not just any arrow this is an arrow that
belongs to Loki and so what we end up
finding out or at least what's being
teased to us here is that between the
time that Loki had gone to his mother
and his mother said get me the Norns and
this moment in 1939 he initiated Asgard
and the result is that he was basically
banished from Asgard proper we just
don't really know why we're not really
sure how all this ended up taking place
and so what we end up doing is we
basically lead to this massive assault
in 1939 by Loki with the frost giants
and this German army all on Asgard and
so again is basically starting this
massive cycle of Ragnarok now this is
interesting because in both the ultimate
universe and the main Marvel line of
comics Loki is always the guy who
basically leaves the charge against
Asgard he's always the guy who brings a
scar down that's just the way it works I
did ask you guys previously how close
the Marvel Comics line of stories were
to like Norse mythology and a lot of you
guys said it's pretty close except for
like these 1 or 2 things so that's
always kind of a cool scenario but the
idea here is that with Loki basically
initiating Asgard the first person to
fall is Balder and that's basically
where all this begins to kick off
Boulder's death trigger the cycle of
Ragnarok and so that's essentially how
this played out look he went to his mom
his mom said give me the Norns Loki went
to go steal the Norns Balder as the eyes
of Odin realized what Loki was doing he
went to go confront him Loki killed him
by accident the cycle of Ragnarok starts
and so what it did is it basically led
all the way up to
1939 when Ragnarok actually begins and
so because of this it's Loki basically
invading Asgard and destroying
everything literally just bringing it
all down around everyone now the problem
with this is that with Odin realizing
Loki was the one who started this what
he basically does is he grabs Loki and
throws him inside of the world tree now
this is important because the world tree
is basically this room with no doors
it's this eternal prison people are not
allowed to leave except under one of two
circumstances the first is that Odin
retrieves them and the second will be
explained at the end of this video so in
response the king of the frost giants
actually ends up killing Odin and so of
course with Odin being killed we end up
having the world tree being totally
obliterated Thor does what he can to
take out the rest of the frost giants
and then he's reborn now in the main
Marvel line of comics this is the post
Ragnarok line of stories to a degree
which is to say the movie as it exists
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
coming out of November it'll actually be
a combination of Planet Hulk and Thor
Ragnarok but in the main Marvel line of
stories there was Thor Ragnarok which
basically led to the destruction of
Asgard everybody basically died all the
Asgardians were gone and then Odin's son
was reborn on earth and then began the
process of travelling around and finding
all the Asgardians restoring mouthguard
back in Broxton Oklahoma and then just
kind of going forward from there this
follows a very similar path the
difference here is that on the surface
he's basically not running around and
waking up as Guardians instead is
actually Balder who comes to him in the
sense that Odin ensured that when he
died both Balder and Thor would be
reborn the difference here is that they
are reborn as humans they are not reborn
as gods and so right now if somebody
were to walk up to Thor in this room
where him and Balder are talking and
they shoot him with a gun he'd be dead
that'd be it but because of the fact
that the two of them are greeting each
other again for the first time because
Balder basically says I have been reborn
in human form and I've been operating
under the name of Donald Lake and I've
been looking for you is basically a
reversal of the main Marvel Universe and
said of Thor tracking down all the
Asgardians Balder has been tracking down
for this is really just Balder saying
the time will come when Owen will return
and the time will come when Asgard will
be restored back to the way it was
before thus is the cycle of Ragnarok
ends so the result is that because these
guys as part of the European government
just need a super-soldier of their own
to really verify the billions of dollars
that they spent what they end up doing
is they give Odin's son this giant
harness that gives him super-strength a
limited amount of invulnerability they
also give him a hammer that allows him
to channel storms and so on and so forth
and then he basically goes forward as
Thor and ends up joining the Ultimates
and so again this is basically his
origin story it's where he comes from is
how all this basically came into play
and is why his hammer looks so cool but
with a tail end of this we end up
catching up on those last three Norn
stones and what we find out is that
while the other 21 stones can be
reshuffled and reworked for the purpose
of accessing the different realms of
Asgard the last three Norn stones no
matter what way you arrange them will
basically be able to access the room
without doors which is to say the place
where Loki is imprisoned and so what
this does is by virtue of helmet Zemo
grabbing the last three Norn stones and
then traveling to this landscape more or
less and activating the stones what it
does is it allows Loki to leave the room
with no doors it frees him from his
imprisonment allowing him to go forward
as basically this guy who's just gonna
do bad things and you know whatever is
it Loki does and so because of this
again it's a pretty cool origin it's a
pretty cool little thing when it comes
to his character but again this is
basically a fresh jumping-off point
because of this is new at this moment
you start jumping into Jonathan
Hickman's Ultimates which is actually a
pretty amazing story and of course
Ultimates and all those stories lead
directly into the collapse of the
multiverse secret wars all those things
Ultimatum I think it is where Galactus
gets thrown into the ultimate universe
after age of Ultron and then him and his
ultimate universe version merged did his
crazy lie he just becomes this crazy
version of Galactus anyway guys if you
are new here to come as explained to
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robb cork if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you